hey guys in this mkbhd video we're going
to be revisiting what i think is the
single most underrated piece of hardware
out there today there are a lot of
consumer electronics that i could have
talked about but i know it's a bit of a
random video but i want to talk to you
guys today about the zune hd by
microsoft i'm even gonna be crazy enough
to put it out there as my number one mp3
player over everything else out there
yeah i know i'm gonna get a lot of
comments saying well you know it's the
holiday season everyone just got their
ipod touch and microsoft really just
missed the boat with the holiday season
sales and the zune hd2 and none of that
really working out but still
nevertheless i think the zune hd really
deserves a shot so let me go ahead and
take a look the awesome pocketable
design of the zune hd is arguably best
in its class and all the buttons around
it are really nicely laid out by
microsoft with the home button up the
front reminds you of the ipod touch of
course and the power button up top and
everything is just nicely spaced also
keep in mind it's only nine millimeters
thick so it's thinner than the thinnest
of the mp3 players out there very very
lightweight as well it has an all black
design in the black version and you can
also get a platinum version which is a
combination of silver and black and that
looks really good too the front of the
device boasts a 3.3 inch high resolution
oled display this contributes to a
number of things first of all it's
ridiculously long battery life i can
literally unplug this thing off the
charger and it'll go for a week without
charging
second it contributes to a very nice
responsive and fun to use ui the user
interface of the zooming gd is based off
of an original operating system that
they later brought over to the windows
phone 7 platform but it's really as you
can see really intuitive really
responsive and it's classified mostly by
speed so if you've ever used a zoom hd
you know that even without a gigahertz
processor it is a really fast device you
can also learn to navigate around it
within a probably about an hour learning
curve there really isn't that much to
learn when getting to use the zoom you
also get to know the hardware buttons on
the side of the device pretty quickly
and you'll get to controlling your music
in your pocket pretty soon even without
looking at the screen in fact i found
that it's easier without a cook wheel to
actually you know adjust the volume and
do things in my pocket when i'm not
looking at the device things that you
just kind of think of like swiping to go
to the next track or dragging up and
down to increase or decrease the volume
are all things that just kind of come
naturally which decreases the learning
curve to the zune hd now there are two
main things that really separate the
ipod touch from the zune hd and i hope
you watch this far into the video the
two things are the marketplace and the
actual gameplay of applications now the
zoom hd has that oled display and colors
really pop when you're actually playing
apps uh versus the retina display which
is an ips display but still is really
nice and also the marketplace in the
zoom hd i mean let's face it it sucks
it's really not that great doesn't have
that many applications but i'll tell you
what application gameplay of that
ferrari app which is one of the key apps
that that really got me you know really
hoping for the zoom hd is incredible
it's really really fun it's difficult to
show you because of the way recording a
screen with a camcorder works so there's
lines on the screen those aren't really
there but the the application gameplay
is actually just phenomenal i couldn't
get enough of it people next to me in
school would be looking over my shoulder
like what is that device you know what
are you playing that on because that
looks really cool and i had to tell them
it was a zune and their jaw probably
just dropped right onto the floor so
overall to wrap it all up if you're
looking for a device that is a a great
media experience for both high
definition music and high definition
radio b is very sleek and portable and
even pocket operatable and c is just an
overall clean
clean lines device nice fancy just looks
really good overall i highly highly
highly highly highly recommend the zune
hd i can't even stress enough how
underrated this device has been i can't
believe that people who call themselves
geeks haven't even heard of or haven't
even given a chance to the zune hd it
does all the little things right from
the the sweet design to zoom pass to hd
radio just all the little things it just
has it all together in this device and i
really really recommend it
so i mean it's kind of like i've just
written a promo for microsoft or some
it's like a youtube channel that has
been doing work for years it hasn't
gotten the exposure it's deserved
this is definitely the type of device
you want to check out so until next time
this has been mkbhd uh be sure to
subscribe if you haven't already and if
you want to go ahead and check out the
new channel design for mkbhd you can
visit that as well until next time mkbhd
signing out peace